meagan Markel isn't above laughing at
her own expense the pregnant Duchess was
a visioning cream as she arrived at the
Mayhew animal charity in North London on
Wednesday marking her first public visit
to her new patronage Meccan turned up
looking absolutely stunning in a very
tight fitting dress from the High Street
brand hmm quite unusual to see her step
out in the High Street but she looks
very very stunning in a 50-dollar
tight-fitting cream dress and a Nnamani
coat
Megan wore her hair down and wavy and
let's not forget her cream-colored
stilettos her heels were so high that
she actually looked a bit wobbly on her
feet at one point but there was no
wobbling when it came to her
interactions check out her flawless
response to one woman's odd greeting
[Music]
we're going to assume she's referring to
the Duchess's growing baby bump earlier
this week
Megan revealed that she's six months
pregnant and is expected to give birth
in late April or early May the couple
have said they don't know the sex of
their baby but back to cute puppies she
looked absolutely delighted to be
meeting quite a few rescue dogs
including a little Jack Russell called
Minnie who was up for adoption today
last week Kensington Palace named meet
you as one of the Duchess's official
patronage is no surprise there as we
know Megan is passionate about animal
welfare so what better way to spend a
rainy London day than cuddling rescue
pups and talking about the importance of
therapy animals Plus Wednesday evening
she and Harry attended the premiere
observe to Sally's totem what we sold
both of the Duchess is out on engagement
today meanwhile Kate Middleton spent her
day at the Royal Opera House where she
met with costume designers and principal
dancers Kate was doing a very different
engagement from Megan and I think that's
really the point I think you're going to
see two different duchesses carving out
two different fields for themselves in
terms of the rumors of the rift and the
pressure that caters under and hope that
really she's trying to rise above it she
wants to put on a united front
last week the Duchess of Cambridge
celebrated her 37th birthday with a
small birthday lunch with close friends
but no Megan and Harry
Megan and Harry weren't invited and that
has really caused things to flare up
again today but a source previously told
ET their absence
doesn't mean there's an ongoing rift
between the royal couple's the source
says that harry has not attended every
birthday celebration
[Music]